[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد لسنوات طويله نجحت
الشركات الاسرائيليه العامله في مجال
الصناعات الدفاعيه والعسكريه في تعزيز
وجودها ادويه سواء في اوروبا او في اسيا
الان باتت هذه الشركات تسعى لتعزيز جودها
في عدد من الدول العربيه والتي بات تربطها
على قاره دبلوماسيه مع تل ابيب بعد
الاتفاقيات الابراهيميه
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل من الدول الان التي بات لها حضور
كبير في مجال الصناعات الدفاعيه والعسكريه
حول العالم الشركات الاسرائيليه بالفعل
نجحت في اختراق الكثير من الاسواق سواء
الاسواق الاوروبيه او حتى الاسواق
الاسيويه من بين هذه الشركات هي شركه اي
اي اي او شركه الصناعه الفضاء الاسرائيليه
هذه الشركه الان وللمره الاولى تشارك
تشارك الدفاع الاسرائيليه في معرض البحرين
الدولي للطيران ماذا خلف هذه المشاركه وما
الذي تسعى اليه الشركات الاسرائيليه ومن
بينها شركه اي اي هذا سيكون محور حديثنا
الان مع السيد معاذ ليفي الرئيس والرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه
الاسرائيليه اولا مستر معاذ اهلا بك معنا
في عسكريتاريا وصفته وجودكم في البحرين
بالفرسى التاريخيه لكن التساؤل ما الذي
تسعى اليه اي اي في البحرين حتى تسعون فقط
لتسويق منتجاتكم تسعون الى شراكه مع الدول
التي باتت الان لديها علاقات مع اسرائيل
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط اهلا اسامه
وانه لا يسرنا ان نتواجد هنا في البحرين
لنمثل قطاع الصناعات الجويه الفضائيه في
اسرائيل هذه لحظه تاريخيه بالنسبه الينا
اذ قامت قيادتنا بفتح الابواب على مصرعها
قبل عامين بتوقيع المعاهده الابراهيميه
وها نحن هنا اليوم كما ان لدينا فعاليات
عده في مختلف انحاء هذه المنطقه في محاوله
لسد الفجوات التي كانت بيننا على مدى سنين
الزعماء فتحوا الطريق امامنا ونحن اتينا
نحمل حلولنا وقدرنا نفيد بها الاخرين
ولنسوق لهذه المنتجات لكننا نتفهم انه من
اجل تسويقها ومن اجل اقامه تعاون جيد بين
اي دولتين لابد من وجود شركات وهذا ما
دعاني
لاقامه علاقات الشراكه
مصر معاذ اي اي الان لديها الكثير من
الحلول الدفاعيه التي تقدمها للكثير من
دول العالم لكن هل كل المنتجات التي
تنتجها شركه اي اي الاسرائيليه هي متاحه
لدول منطقه الشرق الاوسط اقصد طبعا الدول
التي لديها علاقات مع اسرائيل في هذه
المرحله
الجويه الفضائيه الاسرائيليه هي اكبر شركه
دفاعيه في اسرائيل لكننا نقوم ايضا
بنشاطات تجاريه في الشركه تشمل طيران
الشحن وتحويل طائرات الركاب الى طائرات
الشحن نحن نركز على قطاع الدفاع ونشاطاتنا
تشمل الفضاء والجو والبر والبحر لدينا
منتجات في عده مجالات ولدينا تحويل تام من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه من اجل البدء
بالتقدير فكل منتج لدينا حاصل على تصريح
من الحكومه وسبب وجودنا هنا هو اقامه
علاقات التعاون بين الدول وبين القطاعات
المختلفه ونحن ننفذ تعليمات الاسرائيليه
في هذا الشان
بعض الدول الان مصر بوعاد في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط تواجه تهديدات كبيره وتصاعد في
تهديدات تحديدا فيما يتعلق بالمسيرات
وكذلك بالصواريخ البالستيه الحلول
الدفاعيه التي تقدمها اي اي اي الى اي مدى
هي فعاله ضد هذه التهديدات تحديدا فيما
يتعلق بالصواريخ البالستيه وطائرات
والسواريخ البالستيه منتشره في مختلف
انحاء العالم وما يحدث حاليا في اوروبا هو
دليل على ذلك لذلك هنالك طلب عليها ونحن
لدينا الحلول اذ لدينا حلول للدفاعات
الصاروخيه والدفاعات ضد المسجرات وهذا ما
نقوم بتسويقه هنا وفي انحاء العالم واعتقد
ان لدينا سمعه طيبه في مجال الحلول
الدفاعيه الجويه والصاروخيه ونحن نقدم
بعضها هنا اليوم ونجري مفاوضات حاليا مع
دول المنطقه رغم انها ما زالت مفاوضات
مبدايه
انتم في اي اي تقدمونا بعض الحلول
الدفاعيه المرتبطه بالامن السيبراني لكن
وانتم شركه حكوميه اسرائيل تعرضت
لاختراقات سيبرانيه وكذلك قرصنه الكترونيه
الا يوصلت هذا الامر على مدى فعاليه
الحلول الالكترونيه المتعلقه بالامن
السبراني الذي تقدمونها في اي اي
سايبر اتاك ان الهجمات السبرانيه لن تنتهي
لكن هناك مواصفات يجب ان نضعها في انظمهنا
وفي سلوكنا نهيك عن انها جزء من معرفتنا
فهذه الهجمات باتت وقع عن ولابد من ايجاد
اليات لحمايه انظمه وهذا ما نقوم به اعتقد
ان شركهنا من اهم الشركات التي لديها خبره
في مجال الدفاع السرياني ونحن جزء اساسي
من اي نشاطات في هذه المجال
التهديدات في اوروبا الكثير من الشركات
اصبح لديها تزايد في الطلب على الحلول
الدفاعيه التي تقدمها لكن انتم في اي اي
وانتم لكم اسواق في اوروبا وفي اسيا كيف
انعكست هذه الحرب على المنتجات التي تطلب
من اي اي وكذلك كيف انعكست على خطتكم سواء
الحاليه او في المستقبل فنجلد ورد
الان في اوروبا تسجل حقبه جديده من قدره
الانظمه في مجال الدفاع والهجوم ونحن نرى
ان افضل الطرق للتعامل مع هذا التطور ليس
من خلال المنتجات بل في ايجاد حلول لها
وهنا نقصد الحلول الموسعه التي تشمل
التقاط الصور عبر الاقمار الصناعيه الى
جانب القدرات الهجوميه والدفاعيه اذا
لدينا مسيراتنا ومخيرتنا وصواريخنا ونحن
نعمل على تجميع هذه القدرات وتصميمها ضمن
حل واحد شامل وموسع هذا هو الاسلوب الذي
نعتمده ونحن رواد فيه في شركهتنا ومن
المؤكد ان الحرب الحاليه في اوروبا تؤثر
على المستقبل لذلك نحن نعمل للتوصل الى
هذه الحلول
مستر ابو عازليفي رئيس ورئيس التنفيذي
لشركه الصناعه الفضائيه الاسرائيليه شكرا
جزيلا على هذه المقابله